i think she wanted to talk to me like
the first day that it happened and i was
like i don't want to talk to that
b-i-t-c-h
i'm sick of her you take it so much
differently
that's that's first of all that's that's
not true jocelyn
for people of color here's a flower come
on
jocelyn the world has watched you
literally turn into the epitome of
self-made
you have your own show jocelyn's cabaret
season two
is it atlanta number one show in the
country girl like can i just say
again number one show in the country
we're trending weekly a lot of people
like to go back and forth with you on
that
so what are your thoughts on that
because people are quick to be in the
comments and say
no on zeus girl not in the country
but how could it only be on seuss if we
train in the united states weekly and
all they talk about
is jostling cabaret atlanta if
the whole united states is talking about
us
why make them think that that's not what
the pockets and the money
and the numbers are doing okay okay but
you know you can always go to nelson's
ratings
true on wednesdays and see if we're the
number one show in the country
and we are the number one show in the
country okay we're in atlanta this
season
is this something you want to take
around the country where is your like
what's your vision for the future when
it comes to the show
my dream has always been to be a shower
right so what's the best place to go be
a chauver lab
vegas so i want to be in vegas i want to
do residency and um you know i think
that
me and my girls already you'll see in
the show because i notice that we train
every week because they fighting and
they pulling each other's hair but you
got to remember babe
it's a competition the girls were
actually competing to perform with me to
go to vegas so like the girls wasn't
just fighting just to fight the girls
were trying to
eliminate each other because it was 10
ladies in the house and
only four ended up performing with me so
it was a big deal and not only
that they get to go to vegas with me for
season three which is already picked up
and ready to be filmed any minute right
they know they're going to
they know they're going to vegas with me
and they won ten thousand dollars like
the winner won ten thousand dollars
so that's what gets in a lot of fighting
a lot of like just you know double
homicide and
he just had an abortion twins wins
yeah double homicide
[ __ ] that that was like wait what
that was a lot it was a double it was a
lot
it was a lot it was a lot it was a lot
and you know for me
i you know everybody knows i i fight
everybody knows
you know from my pirate shows loving
hip-hop and stuff like that everybody
know i'm ready to whoop
ass any minute it's like let's do it but
i couldn't just fight every time a young
lady
said something that i didn't feel like
it was right but it was hard it was hard
to hear that because
i didn't think it was nice how do you
feel when you hear the constructive
i guess you would call it constructive
criticism because even the coughing
moment that recently happened
that went viral tell them you want to
leave because and one of the closest
partners of the network
who are you popping at i want to talk
about aqua i know you weren't popping at
me
like damn is that serious right now when
you went off on that girl for coughing
you got into well you went in the shade
room and said that it was more to the
story
so how do you feel when you receive that
constructive criticism do you take a
look at it
or do you just kind of brush it off
listen i was in the house with these
girls
for like literally a month right these
girls did so much shady stuff to me
that by the fifth or sixth day i was
ready for them
i was ready i was like okay honestly she
said she choked and you see
you seen on the tape i stopped i was
like okay [ __ ] you better be choking in
water
but right i really don't think she
choked the water i really think that she
was being
at vitch i really thought that she was
upset with me
because i called her out in front of the
other ladies you messed up
suck it up eat it up and let's get back
to work so i wanted to call her out and
in the midst of me calling her out
she started coughing like i was a germ
now we know i'm not a germ
no i'm not a jerk so why is she doing
all that coughing
girl i was like i was like did you get
triggered because you're not like
stuff like that happens when you grow up
people disrespect you in certain ways
they may
trigger me absolutely not absolutely
not let me tell you something okay you
can tell me something
so sick in my face and i will not give
you a reaction
yeah i would not give you a reaction so
she didn't that she
did not trigger me but i needed her to
know and all the other ladies
to know that when i'm talking right i
don't care if you got to take a poop
hold it
jocelyn in your eyes it was
disrespectful it was very and i think
that she lied
to me in my face about saying she was
choking on water
she did drink a little water prior to me
calling her out for the people because i
see her with the with the water but
nah nah nah you was you you you was
disrespecting me and i called you out
and the stories
are just starting to like open up a
little bit more and you'll get to me
see everybody's personality and you'll
definitely understand
why i told her okay he ain't gonna be
coughing while i'm talking
i can't let you go without talking about
the interview
the interview that was seen around the
world with miss wendy
williams it seemed as if you were trying
to speak up for every celebrity
who has not had a chance to say
something or who has not said anything
even if they had a chance
how did her response sit with you as you
look back at it
she was very rude and you know as a host
no matter who you are you still should
be respectful to the people that sits in
front of you and speaks to you and give
you their story or their time and their
conversation
so my thing is like when she threw the
flowers at me
she was being real disrespectful and not
acknowledging the fact that when
latinas and black women sit on her
couch she's always going for
an annihilation like she comes out with
a gun right
but she don't give me my props or
nothing that i do like
i'm 35 years her junior
and she don't give me no problems like
girl i'm doing big things out here i got
two
shows that i own i franchise
i'm doing my thing i got an actual
cabaret show that we're going to vegas
next season like
but you always want to compare me with
people and and i think she does it to
every person that's of color
because she doesn't want nobody of color
to be better than her
like women when it comes down to women
right or
man so for me it's like you're not the
only one that could sit up there
and be powerful and you have
a voice so put your brothers and sisters
on a high level don't push this down
it's so old it's so played out it's so
shady and i think the audience want to
see a difference
so i just don't know how her producers
and the
and the puppet masters out there who who
strangle her alone
didn't see that the way she acted
towards me
35 years a lady that's 35 years younger
than her
i don't see how they didn't think that
that was problematic and it's not a
problem because we really need to change
the way
the world is moving i agree with you on
that i will say i was proud of you
because you you didn't go off like i
thought you would you could definitely
see a change in
you know your growth over the years has
she reached out to you
at all you know i think she wanted to
talk to me like the first day that it
happened i was like i don't want to talk
to that b-i-t-c-h
i'm sick of her you know i'm saying my
thing is like come on now
you know the people everybody applauded
me you know everybody was like i thought
you should have told her that what you
did tell her and
my thing is like you know i thought that
she would change
okay but what what do we expect though
because she's built a career
off of being shady and while i get where
you're coming from you know
as a black woman wanting that respect
and return
it's kind of like it's windy though
that's why we sit and say how you doing
because we know
that yeah yeah that's true it is that is
true but
what's also true that when you've been
in the industry for so many years
you have to reinvent yourself yeah
because it comes to time when people get
sick of looking at you and hearing you
so it's time to reinvent yourself
and i think it's just one of those times
that she needs to reinvent herself
because especially with the kobe 19 i
know her ratings has been
way low ain't nobody sitting up there
watching you girl people got to figure
out okay okay so
so so let's talk about that jocelyn
because
you're shading her too right just you
you shade it you shake it wendy too
i looked in the comments on the video
just to see what other fans were saying
and there were some people that were
basically saying
that you shouldn't want someone else to
validate you or you shouldn't need
that or need someone to give you flowers
so what's your response to those people
who are thinking
in that mind frame well i didn't do this
for her to validate me or to get
validation from anybody the world has
given me validation by making johnson
discovery atlanta the number one show in
the country
so they've already validated me a long
time ago
before i sat up in front of the broad
face to tell her a piece of my mind
i more so gave her a piece of my mind
because when you've got little children
coming out like my daughter i hope she
doesn't choose to be in the
entertainment industry but let me just
tell you something she loves to sing
and for her to fall asleep she's got to
sing so i don't know where she gonna go
with it
she said she wants to be a scientist we
just don't know what she's gonna be
but if any case my daughter is gonna
come
and be an entertainment like her mommy
anytime she sit in front of anybody
they're gonna respect her
they're going to respect her and so i
just feel like i needed to do this just
not for my daughter
but for the other little girls that are
coming down behind me for them to stand
their ground and don't let
nobody disrespect them you said that
wendy should do a better job at
uplifting black women women of color
there are also people that feel like
your shell johnson's cabaret doesn't do
a great job at that so what's your
response to that
listen justin is gabriele is doing a
great job giving these ladies an
opportunity to be a better woman
how they act i have nothing to do with
that i don't produce my ladies
my ladies know what it is it's a
competition for you to come
compete to perform in the cabaret itself
that we're going to be having in vegas
this is an actual they're they're
competing to being something right
so when you're in a competition your
energy and your attitude and the way you
act all completely changes because
you're like
this is like a life or death situation
so
i'm sorry that the ladies aren't kumbaya
kumbaya kumbaya
but they can't be kumbaya when they
trying to get to vegas and be
in the show jostling's cabaret this has
nothing to do with the tv show itself
these girls are competing to be in the
actual show so if they fight they argue
they do what they're gonna do they don't
care about what nobody thinks about that
and me
if i was in their in their shoes i
wouldn't care either
if i want something in life i'm gonna do
what i need to do to get it
and i think as the show progresses
i think that the audience are going to
be able to understand a little bit why
some of the ladies acted the way that
they're active
i'm only bringing you the ladies the
ladies has to present themselves
i can't i can't present the ladies for
you that's their own presentation to do
honestly i want the ladies to change and
become better woman and i think you guys
will get to see them becoming better
women
as the show goes on and a lot of these
ladies go through a lot of personal
things that's why we have
the psychiatrist was in the house so i
did a lot to help these ladies
and the audience will be able to see
that will you ever go back on wendy
williams
i mean if she wants some good writing
she needs to have me back anyways too
let me know that you know what jocelyn i
learned from what you told me
you were right